ونصل الان مشاهدينا الى فقره تضيف اليوم
رئيس الروسيه كان قد اكد يوم امس الخميس
انه منفتح على الحوار مع اوكرانيا شرط ان
تقبل اكياس مسماها الوقائع الجديده على
الارض عقب الهجوم الروسي شروط سرعت
اوكرانيا الى رفضها واصفه اياها بغير
المقبوله وهو موضوع فقره اليوم ضيف ضيف
اليوم ضيفنا هو سيد محمد رجب بركات الخبير
في العلاقات الدوليه اهلا وسهلا بك بدايه
هل يمكن ان نسميها همم
انفتاح على الحوار
والمفاوضات همم هذا التصريح من قبل بلاد
ليفربول
في الواقع هذا التصريح اتصالات جرت بين
الرئيس بوتين والرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان الذي يبدو انه اقنعه في موافقه
على وقفه اطلاق النار خلال فتره الاعياد
لمده 36 ساعه وطبعا اقترح الرئيس بوتين
قدم هذا الاقتراح ولكن من الجانب
الاوكراني ومن الجانب الامريكي هذا
الاقتراح لم يبدا اي قبول وذلك بحجه او
بدايه
الجيش الروسي يريد اخذ راحه لمده ثلاثه
ايام او يومين كي يتمكن من
التسلح بشكل اكبر العوده والهجوم مره
ثانيه ولكن نجد انه في هذه الحاله اعتقد
تركيا لديها علاقه جيده مع اوكرانيا او
لديها علاقه جيده مع روسيا وهي عضو في
شمال الاطلسي بامكانها ان تقوم
ببساطه دور الوسيط تماما كما قامت السابق
انت معتم الاتفاق على شحن المواد الغذائيه
الحبوب والقمح من اوكرانيا همم باشراف
ومساعده تركيه
بركات بعيدا عن الوساطه التركيه همم اريد
ان افهم منك ورايك همم في هذا هذا
الانفتاح الذي اوحى به رئيس الوسيله
بانهم منفتح على مفاوضات مع
اوكرانيا لكن في الوقت نفسه همم وضع شروطا
ومن بينها ان تقبل اوكرانيا بالوضع القائم
اي ان همم روسيا تضم اجزاء كبيره من شرق
اوكرانيا
طبعا هذا الاقتراح واعتقد انه في كافه
الاقتراحات من اجل التفاؤل هناك امكانيه
للتفاوض وربما التراجع عن هذا الموقف
والعوده الى مكان تطلب روسيا قبل الحرب
كانت تطلب ان لا تنضم اوكرانيا الى حف
شمال الاطلسي وان يتم تطبيق اتفاقيات من
وذلك حفاظا على حقوق قليات الروسيه
الذين يتحدثون الروسيه والموجودين داخل
المناطق الاربعه التي قامت روسيا بضمها
مؤخرا ولكن طبعا هذا الاقتراح الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
اشارت منذ فتره الى انه لا يمكن قبول اي
حل سلمي ما دام هناك جنود همم روس داخل
الاراضي الاوكرانيات بما فيها شبه جزيره
في القانون وهذا ايضا الموقف الذي تبناه
الرئيس الاوكراني الان دول حشومه الاطلسي
تقول انها لا تشارك بشكل مباشر في الحرب
على اوكرانيا همم الحادثه اوكرانيا ولكن
همم نجد انها ترسل الاسلحه ترسل بطاريات
صواريخ باتريوت تقوم بتدريب القوات
الاوكرانيه هناك وهناك انتقادات لبعض
المسؤولين الاوروبيين وعلى راسهم الرئيس
الفرنسي الذي حاول مرارا ان يكون كوسيط
يقوم بدور كوسيت وعندما خاصه عندما قال
بانه لا يجب ان تهان روسيا خلال هذه الحرب
وهذا دليل على محاوله من فرنسا الى التوسط
ولكن طبعا يبدو ان الجانب الامريكي
والبريطاني خاصه همم
يدفعني الجيش الاوكراني والرئيس الاوكراني
الى عدم قبول ايجاد حل سلمي حاليا
وطبعا الان بعض التصريحات من المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين اعتبروا انفسهم وكانهم اعضاء
في الشمال الاطلسي كان مؤخرا من هذا
التصريح اعتقد صباح اليوم همم لانه يحصلون
على الاسلحه وهمم
يحصلون على التدريبات العسكريه ومبارك
بالضبط في هذه النقطه سيد همم محمد رجاء
بركات مع اعلان فرنسا تزويده اوكرانيا
بدبابات خفيفه بعضها انضمت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والمانيا بالاعلان عن
تقديم اسلحه نوعيه جديده الى اوكرانيا هل
لازلنا همم في صدد الحديث عن حرب بين كياب
وموسكو ام موسكو وبدا الحلف شمال الاطلسي
مثل ما همم يقول الروس
اعتقد يعني منطقيا تم توجيه انتقادات
لايران على سبيل المثال بانها تشارك في
الحرب بقى على اوكرانيا وذلك لانها ارسلت
طائرات بدون طيار الى روسيا الان دول
الحلف شمال الاطلسي ااا كافه تقوم بارسال
الاسلحه وتقوم بتدريب جنون
اوكرانيين وتتعمليه
واستخباراتيا المعلومات والجيش الاوكراني
عن حول مراكز ومواقع الجيش الروسي وفي نفس
الوقت تقول انها لا تشارك بشكل مباشر في
الحرب يعني اعتقد انه يعني بدون تبني اي
موقف سياسي همم طرف او اخر ولكن ناحيه
منطقيه يعني هذه الامور بدات واضحه ومن
يتحمل همم ما يجري حاليا نتائج السلبيه
لما يجرح حاليا الرئيس
الاوكراني لمده سنوات عندما كان ممثلا
فكاهيا وها هو الان مع الرئيس بوتين همم
تسبب
بسبب الحرب ااا الازرار كبيره والقتلى في
والدمار في اوكرانيا او ايضا
الاوساط السياسيه في اوروبا
طبعا همم
الان مع الاسف بكل صراحه في اوروبا لا
يترك مجال لتوجيهي الانتقادات لمواقف
الاتحاد الاوروبي واحد شمال الاطلسي ما
يجري حاليا كم من الممكن بشكل واضح همم
وتجنب وقوع هذه الحرب قبل ان تقع عندما
كان الرئيس الروسي يطالب بعدهم ضم
اوكرانيا الى حد شمال الاطلسي والتطبيق
اتفاقي ولكن وجدنا انه كان من الرئيس
التصريحات تشير الى انه لا يمكن قبول ذلك
اندلعت الحرب والنتائج الان يتحملها
الجميع واول الاطراف التي تتحمل هذه
النتائج واكثر همم الاطراف وتضررا اعتقد
انها دول الاتحاد الاوروبي وشرب الاوربيه
في العلاقات الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا